we all remember Teresa May in her first
speech as Prime Minister pledging to
fight the burning in justices of
inequality and politicians of all
stripes have championed the idea of
social mobility of creating equal
opportunities for all regardless of
background and yet it just hasn't worked
as it stands in the UK it would take
five generations for poorer families to
reach the average income that's because
people can't climb up in a society
that's unequal and in Britain which by
some measures is one of the most unequal
countries in Europe we have inequality
levels that belong to the 1930s you
can't tackle social mobility when there
are such wide gaps between rich and poor
when half of England is owned by 1% of
the population when 1 in 3 children
lives in poverty when students from the
top 9 private schools are 94 times more
likely to join the British elite when
children educated anywhere else
as a policy objective social mobility
has failed switching our focus to social
justice and wealth redistribution is far
more likely to address those burning and
justices across the nation well that's a
statistic one in three children live in
poverty define poverty so this is not a
new statistic this has been around for
quite a while and it's something that
actually we could look at how much is it
what's week everybody per week poll
burns but we could look at the UN
special Special Rapporteur on extreme
poverty and Human Rights Philip Austen
because he there's a different way
actually you've proved to me that food
is not a load of cobblers he answered
it's a UN report nobody give me the me
give me the money give me the answer for
fact is that 60% of median earnings do
you know what median earnings is at 20
something's else yeah yeah 27 28 so
we're talking about 16 16 17 thousand
pound per annum right and that's poverty
tell that to the pensioners watching
this Nick I feel like you're not really
living in this country if you don't
understand the rate of poverty that
you're experiencing I don't I don't know
because you look
fifteen thousand down the country Nick
we have people who are living into
poverty let's have a listen to what
Philip Alston said he is the Union
Special Rapporteur on extreme poverty
and human rights let's have a listen to
what unit the results of the austerity
experiment are crystal clear there are
14 million people living in poverty
record levels of hunger and homelessness
falling life expectancy for some groups
ever fewer community services and
greatly reduced policing UK standards of
well-being have descended precipitously
in a remarkably short period of time as
a result of deliberate policy choices
made when many other options are
available so what he has said is that
this is a choice that that you know one
of the most frustrating things about
looking at the level of hardship in this
country because we have an economy that
isn't working for most people and one of
the most frustration things about that
is that sense of inevitability it
doesn't actually have to be that way we
can reprogram the economy to make it
work in a way that is fairer for all
people and the reason going back to my
original subject the reason that social
mobility hasn't worked in the UK is
living that it has failed is that you
cannot have social mobility in a society
where is Varys [ __ ] the Jeremy Corbyn it
falls upon me it seems again to produce
the response about some of the targets
in this debate so the Department for
Work and Pensions would like to come
yeah and they said we take tackling
poverty extremely seriously which is why
we spend 95 billion pounds a year on
welfare and maintain a state pension
system that supports people into
retirement all the evidence shows that
full-time work is the best way to boost
your income and quality of life which is
why our welfare reforms are focused on
supporting people into employment and we
introduce the National living wage so
people earn more in work what I'd like
to say actually is when I first came
across this and I'm really happy you're
raising this subject I think inequality
is one of the pressing issues of our day
then why I'm skeptical of Allston I
think the way these appointments happen
is somebody in the UN because he worked
for free did it for free it's not like
it's not a paid appointment he was a
professor in New York so on says I like
his
why don't you point him and it's a bit
of a political appointment I'm skeptical
of him but it's a really important topic
and I think actually but when I first
read it though or came across it as a
laborer announcement it did feel to me a
bit like a dig at the new labor years as
well
and I just want to be yeah I just want
to bring in old Tony Blair who actually
is looking rather old in this but let's
have a look at what he says we made the
UK more equal more fair and more
socially mobile and we never ever said
inequality didn't matter or that
tackling it was not a priority of the
government of course like any government
with false failures and did things
people disagreed with but don't tell me
all those who work with me or those who
were part of the Labour Party at the
time that we did nothing for the poorest
in our country or the world well the
reason I reason I brought him in rate
choice because mr. Corbyn began his
announcement with the words for decades
we've been told that inequality doesn't
matter now the word decades includes
them absolutely and so Mr Blair
responded and that was a response
specifically for the announcement and he
said don't tell us we didn't care about
inequality I'm not meaning me as in him
and and and he felt quite in sorts of
other I kind of sympathize with his
perspective because I think is a really
important topic but I seem to remember
the New Labour years and they did care
about inequality so there's there's a
couple of so one of the things about
that is that you know there's it's
decades for a reason now Tony Blair a
new labour they did kept they did care
about raising people out of poverty they
introduced measures to try and tackle
that SureStart is a very good example
although the government has now shot
those down literacy and they did they
did but they bought into a nikhat
economic system which we have had for 30
years hence the decades they bought into
that economic system they thought as
long as we just you know put in some
short start programs it will be fine
wealth will trickle down but the reality
was that the the economic system in
itself is creating that inequality Danny
darling the social geography geography
he calls Tony Blair the king of
inequality because actually during that
period of New Labour during that period
of
that's the problem would it be okay if
we just could it be okay if we just put
a pause on the name-calling the most
important and significant boost to
social mobility in this society came
through the 1970s 1980s and 1990s and it
came for don't shake your head it's true
it came for a very specific reason which
was there was a massive expansion in
need for white-collar jobs that is why
people like me and probably other people
around this table got to University and
got professional jobs my family the
people who worked in uniforms you know
the reason I was able to get in was
because there was an expansion and a
change in the economy it had very little
- of things you're talking about the
question we got to deal with now is how
do we make sure that we keep that going
what you seem to be proposing is that
you know we're in a building we're all
on the ground floor what you want to do
is to take away the stairs so nobody can
climb to the second floor but simply
just bring down the second floor to the
same level and bring up the basement we
say on the ground floor that's precisely
the point Rachel Rachel what we get
honest if what you want to do is to say
let's soak the bloody rich let's take
their land away let's tax them to the
hilt I am actually rather with you on
that what I can't smell what I can't
what I can't stand is this sort of this
kind of mimsy oh we're going to do
something about social justice if what
you want to do is attack privilege say
that's what you want to do listen from
the rich let's do from the are you
saying because you're talking about
changing entire economic so are you
anti-capitalist is that what we're
talking about the question because I was
wondering that yeah I usually capsulate
so that's that's precisely the point
it's about I actually think when we talk
about social mobility it's interesting
because we always work yes or no I'm
going to answer that question that
promise because when we talk about
social mobility we always talk about it
in terms of people from poorer
backgrounds going upwards we never talk
about privileged people having to let go
of a bit of their privilege so then that
were not reproducing it
for some people to come up some people
have to come down I've found I've
followed this debate with interest in
terms of moving away from the wired
searcher mobility to the wide social
justice and actually I think if I
correct me if I'm wrong so now we want
to replace a social mobility commission
with a social justice commission that
right yeah which to me is going full
circle because the social the social
mobility Commission used to be call at
the child poverty Commission which then
went on to social mobility and is now
going social justice and it is a fact
that you can't have social justice
without social mobility social you've
got to tackle social mobility social
economics
and so sorry social exclusion and
poverty and I just feel a little bit
like what's going on I don't know I
don't is we are using these trendy words
to pitch us against them and them
against you and they are bad and you are
good and we're going to be the saviors
that's gonna fix this and I just find it
a little bit but also can I just like
what your question I think was a really
pertinent one because what I don't
understand is what what about what you
just said in response to Michelle's
question did Tony Blair not do public
spending went up when he became 97 when
he came in it went up from 35% and then
over the course of that next decade so
45% what is it he did not do that you're
not happy he maintained an economic
system that exaggerated no I don't agree
with the free market if exaggerated in
qualities you'd have to listen to me as
ft the FT reported but during New
Labour's rules what system do you want
there was inequality increase this is a
terrible thing about the Corbin Easter's
you want to bury Tony Blair don't but
you cannot bring yourselves to have the
courage simply to say we're Marxists we
will everything change let's kill it
yeah
just say it yeah you might mean don't
pretend you're saying something that
you're not I don't have a problem with
Marxist economic systems aha neither do
I have any problem with crediting Tony
Blair for introducing things like Shore
star it's not either all